- Hi.
- Oh, hey, what's up?
- Hey.
(Jess giggles)
- What's up?
- So in case you forgot, my name's Jess,
but you can call me Mommy.
- I'm not, no!
(Jess laughs)
(upbeat music)
- I'm a very polar person,
so I don't think I should be in the front,
because I'm more polarizing.
- But I feel like when you
have a huge personality,
you're more gravitating.
- But it could be scary too!
- You know what though?
You give like a very sensual, sweet,
music video girl vibe.
- Yes!
- Like, I swear dudes love
watching music videos,
so they're like, "Oh my
god, the girl of my dreams."
I think you should be first.
- Yes.
- Me?
- Yes!
- Wait, what? I thought
we were talking about her!
- Wait guys, guys,
we don't have to finalize it now.
Let's just start moving people.
- Let's start tossing around.
- You're not last.
- You are not last,
I'll tell you right now.
- You were doing Naruto
runs around the room.
- No.
- I'm like, uh okay.
This is hard, because you're really funny.
- Who, me?
- Yes you!
- You're naturally gravitating too.
- Hmm.
(indistinct chatting)
- I like all of us.
Just for the record, I
don't think I have rizz.
I would not have ranked
myself where I was at.
- But we have to think from a, if we can,
the most we can think
from a guys perspective.
Who's the most approachable.
- (beep) Their opinions.
(giggling)
- If I like a guy, I'm
avoiding eye contact.
- No, literally!
- It's like if I don't
find a dude attractive,
I could go up to him and be like,
"Hey, what's your name?"
But the moment I find a guy attractive,
I'm like, oh my God, like,
- So like no eye contact rizz?
- Because I get nervous,
you know what I mean?
- This is my approach.
If I'm in a bar, I'm like,
"Hi, my name is Jaz,
I just thought you were really handsome
and I wanted to introduce myself."
- Oh!
- Oh yeah, you need to stay where you are!
You need to stay there.
- All right, you stay there.
- Number two is true,
number two is definitely locked in.
- I don't go to a guy and be like, oh,
directly, you're handsome.
I'll try to get to know your psyche,
like get you to open up.
- Next thing you know, she
pulls out the tarot cards.
All right, I'm gonna do
a tarot card reading.
- And then see if you're gonna crack.
I do the psychological game.
- I think we're good.
- Okay, we're gonna lock it in.
(upbeat music)
- [Presenter] How's everyone feeling?
- No nerves.
- [Presenter] No nerves?
- 'Cause we're getting rizzed.
It's up to them.
- I've never been nervous
before in my entire life.
- [Presenter] That's good.
Have you guys ever been rizzed by a girl?
- No.
- Not really.
- They've looked at us.
- Yeah
They've looked at us.
- It's like the little side eye.
They walk, they look at you,
and they keep walking.
But the rest is up to you.
- But girls don't have rizz though.
I've never--
- Maybe they have their
friend come up or something,
but, you know, they're not doing it.
- They've got the little brushes.
They do some of this.
- That's about it.
- That's girl rizz, I think.
- [Presenter] Is there
something they could do
that would be an immediate turn off?
An L rizz?
- Trying too hard.
- Overconfident.
- Yeah, just trying too hard.
Like, too much.
- And you're thinking, how
many dudes are you approaching?
- Yeah, I don't like that.
- If they come at me twerking,
I'm like, okay,
hold on!
- Twerking?
- I think that'd be cool.
- I was about to say,
they can be twerking.
- I would be okay with that.
- That's chill, I'll take it.
I'll take it.
- I think if they just talked to me,
and there are a few things that I don't,
like interests and stuff.
If they start talking about NFT's,
I'd be like, what are you talking about?
- [Presenter] So Errol and Nut,
you guys were both on the
Rizz episode last time.
- We're back, we're here.
- [Presenter] How are you feeling
being on the opposite end?
- I'm excited, you know?
I'm nervous for the girls to
see what they're gonna do,
but I'm excited.
This time we're getting rizzed.
- I feel like it's like a spa day.
- Yeah, we're just chilling right now.
- Watching the first episode
of guys rizzing girls,
I was like...
I hope girls are not like that,
'cause some guys be saying
some weird stuff sometimes.
- I may not be able to take you
from the vava to the cinquante-cinq,
then back to the vava,
if you know you know.
- [Host] Rizz.
- [Ammara] Hi!
- How's it going?
- Hi, I'm Ammara.
- Hi, I'm Errol.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Presenter] Were you nervous?
- For her.
- Where are you from, may I ask?
- Originally from Philadelphia,
but I kind of grew up all over.
You?
- I'm from Chino Hills.
- Really, okay?
- Um, yeah.
Can I just say your eyes are so pretty.
- Thank you, I appreciate that--
- Yeah, they're like literally shining,
and I'm so sorry I keep
on looking at your hands.
They kind of look heavy.
Yeah, would you like me
to hold them for you?
- Oh, I like her.
- So with that being said, right,
- I like her.
- what are we doing after this?
We're gonna go eat--
- We can eat.
- Have you watched "La La Land" before?
- I haven't.
- Oh, neither have I.
- We can both watch it together--
- But we can go to the observatory,
have a little picnic, you
know, watch the sunset?
- A woman with plans, I like that.
Okay!
- Yeah.
- I like her, she's nice.
I like her.
(clapping)
- I am literally shaking.
- The delivery almost rizzed
through him and to us.
- Hey!
- How you doing?
- Hold on, I wanna see you from here.
Okay, okay!
You looking real good today.
- Your turn.
- Oh!
- How you doing?
- You're so sweet, hey.
- I'm doing good.
You look good though.
- You look good too.
- Thank you.
- I like the blue.
- Hold on.
- What's up?
- Oh, she's smelling him!
- I smell good, smell me.
- Yeah,
you do smell really good--
- Lemme smell you now.
- Okay, go for it.
Oh, okay.
- You smell good too.
- Thank you, Garrett.
Okay.
- Getting a little sweaty.
- So what do you like to do?
- I'm a MMA fighter, so
I have to train a lot.
So I'm training every day.
So you know I can protect you.
- I'm down for it.
- Erica and Garrett were getting it on!
It was actually getting hot.
I was like, oh my gosh.
The way she did a little
spin and he was smelling her.
It was a lot.
- What do you like to do?
I like to watch anime and I cosplay.
- Anime?
What do you cosplay as?
- So I just dress up as
any little anime character.
- Can I make a couple special requests?
- Yeah!
- Okay, cool.
I'm gonna get you some requests later.
- Okay, I'll definitely dress up for you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
- Gimme a hug.
- I hope that's two minutes.
- I feel taken care of with you.
I feel taken care of with her.
- Of course.
- That was exciting.
(Erica giggles)
- Hi.
- Hi. How you doing?
Oh, straight for the hug, okay.
- Nice to meet you.
- What's your name?
- My name's Ivan.
And your name is Mai?
- Mai.
- Yeah.
Are you from LA?
- I'm like,
I say I'm from LA 'cause it's easier,
but I'm from like out East.
- Oh really?
- I'm from out east where like
people don't really know like
the cities or anything.
- Where's out east?
- I live in Chino Hills.
- Oh, okay.
I live in Chino Hills.
Do you know where that is?
- No, I'm Canadian, so I'm like,
Chino Hills?
I just flew in yesterday.
- Oh!
- Yeah. Just for this.
- So you're not from here then?
- No.
- Damn, she said long
distance off the bat.
- Maybe you're just the lucky one.
Actually, I live in New York though, so.
- I was in New York last year.
- Really?
Why didn't you hit me up?
- I didn't know you yet.
- I swear I DM'd you last year.
- Oh, did you now?
- You didn't see it?
- Maybe you should DM me again.
- Mm. Are you doing anything after this?
- Actually not.
- I might need a tour guide.
I wouldn't wanna get lost, you know.
- Okay.
- She's good.
- Okay. She is good.
- Damn
- Can I get your number?
- I mean, if I have my phone.
- Imaginary phone.
- Imaginary phone, okay.
- All right.
Well, I'm gonna get back to my girls,
but I'll text you.
(clapping)
- That's a dog.
(Mai laughs)
- Hi.
- How are you?
- I'm good, Jimmy.
- I'm Aurora.
Nice to meet you.
Are you from the area?
- Yeah.
- Okay. Okay.
I'm from Redlands.
- You don't want to drink?
- No. what do you like to drink?
What do you get to drink?
- What do I get to drink?
I get to drink mojitos.
- Mojitos?
- Yeah.
- Stop. Because,
- That's your favorite? Oh--
- We might be,
(slapping sound effect)
That is my favorite.
I always go for mojito.
- Okay, yeah.
- I feel like people who
go for mojito are like,
they like the--
- What am I giving?
- It's like rare.
It's like you like the spice of life.
You like things that might be
a little bit more out
of pocket, eccentric.
- Out of pocket.
- So maybe you're spontaneous.
- A little bit. Yeah, yeah.
All of the above.
- Spontaneous?
- Super.
- Yes.
- Yeah, yeah.
We could just get--
Line 'em up with mojitos, back to back.
Let's see who gets drunk faster.
Down?
- Yes.
- Okay. I'm sorry.
I feel like I'm doing the--
- No you're--
- I know, I'm like, okay.
I'm trying to get to know you right now.
- Yeah, you should keep going.
- Yeah, no,
I love mojitos.
What else do you like to drink?
- Um,
Orange juice.
- Okay.
- Like Sunday mornings.
- So you were doing this
when you said that you're from here.
So are you like,
- Oh no, I'm from New York originally.
- Oh, you're from New York?
- Yeah.
- I've been wanting to visit there.
- Okay.
- So,
- Yeah.
- Have you ever been to Brooklyn?
- Brooklyn, Manhattan,
all the boroughs.
- Yes. You're gonna take me around.
So do you travel a lot, or?
- Yeah, yeah, I travel a lot.
I got my amex card.
I got a lot of points.
- Okay.
- Done.
Oh, okay.
- Wow. That was so good.
[Presenter] Jess and Nut.
Let's go.
(Jess laughs)
Redemption arc.
- We're supposed to be at a bar again?
- We're at a bar again.
- Okay.
- Wherever you want.
- I have the clammiest hands right now.
(giggles)
Hi.
- Oh, hey.
- Hey.
- What's up?
- So in case you forgot my name's Jess,
but you can call me Mommy.
- I'm not--
No, I'm not gonna do that.
(Jess laughs)
- Why would I?
- That's okay.
I just gave myself the ick too.
It's okay.
- Glad we're on the same page.
- We are.
- Cool.
What's up? How's it going?
- Good, how are you doing?
- I'm doing great.
- Um,
(cast laughs)
Did you have a bad day?
- No. I've been having
a good day, actually.
One of the better days, so,
- Oh my god.
- Do you like bad girls?
- Do I like bad girls?
- Mm hmm.
- Like what kind of way?
Like a detention?
- No.
- I got a, a ticket once
'cause I was playing Pokemon Go.
- Well that's in the car
while you were driving.
- No, I wasn't driving.
- How do you get a ticket
when you're not driving?
- Well, I pulled over to capture chars.
- So you were in your car driving?
- Yeah, but I wasn't on the gas.
- Okay. Well you were still driving.
- But it was really naughty.
And then I also had tinted windows,
so it was like double bad.
- So, it was dangerous, just all-around.
Also though, unrelated.
I also just got a car ticket. $70.
- Is that why you're grumpy?
- I'm not grumpy.
- Yeah.
- No, I'm not.
(Jess laughs)
I'm not. I'm not,
I'm actually feeling really good.
- It was like flirting with a soggy towel.
Even being salty with him,
I still set him up for jokes
and I was like, you're giving me nothing.
So my love language is gift-giving.
- I like receiving things.
Did you bring any gifts?
- I brought this in case you rizzed
in the bathroom before coming out here.
- Okay, so--
(Jess laughs)
Thank you.
I'm gonna give it back to you.
- You Don't like my gift?
- The tissue? No, but
I thought it was funny.
- Maybe next time I see you,
now that I know you a little better.
- Yeah.
- I can bring you a better gift.
- For sure.
Thank you very much. Okay.
I thought that was fun.
(cast clapping)
- You're mean.
- I'm mean? No I'm not!
(Jess laughs)
- I'm sorry I didn't
think I was being mean.
My bad.
- I forgive you.
- I thought we were having fun.
- Don't mind if I do.
- Hi, my name's Jaz.
- Jimmy.
Nice to meet you.
- I thought I would just
come introduce myself.
I thought you're super handsome.
I know you're with your boys, so.
- Oh yeah.
You know, I don't wanna interrupt
whatever you guys are celebrating.
- They're creeping right now,
looking over us.
- But, I thought I would come
introduce myself and let
you know I exist, and,
- Oh, you exist already.
Right in front of me.
- What are you guys celebrating tonight?
- It's my--
- Hanukkah.
- Hanukkah. It's my boy's Hanukkah.
- Okay, cute.
- Yeah.
You know, it's just,
we don't typically go out on Hanukkah but,
yeah, yeah,
No, it's tradition actually, right?
- Yes.
- I just don't get invited.
- Eighth day.
Woo woo.
- Okay, anyways.
Um,
I would like to take you out sometime.
- Okay.
- Show you how I roll.
- How I do things.
- How do you roll?
What are you rolling to?
- You have to come and find out.
- Oh.
- All right.
- Let's come find out and see.
- Okay, so let me find out then.
Hold on.
Yeah. Put my number
down so I can find out.
Yeah, take my number
Yeah.
- What do you want me to set my name as?
- Huh?
- What do you want my name as?
- Just take a picture.
I'll remember it.
- I'm gonna put my name as Baby,
- Baby, baby.
- We're getting into it.
I got his Instagram, so I don't know.
He was nice.
[Presenter] Think something's
gonna happen there?
- I don't know. I guess
I'll have to find out.
- Okay.
- Don't go giving it
to your boys and stuff.
- No, no, no.
This is just for me.
- You won't call me?
- Huh?
Oh. Absolutely.
That's right after the show.
- All right.
- Yeah.
(Jaz laughs)
(cast clapping)
- Yeah, the youtuber, what's her name?
- Oh, the Canadian.
- Mai, Mai, Mai, Mai.
- Yes.
- It was chill.
I thought it was kinda like normal. Right?
- It was like chill.
- It wasn't awkward.
- I still feel like his girl was first.
- She was pretty good.
She smelled good.
- She was good.
- She looked good.
- I will be fully transparent.
I thought everyone was good,
and I don't know how
I would distinguish any of them.
Or I was just distracted.
I'm very easily distracted.
I saw like a fly
and then I was looking
at the fly for a second
and someone was talking.
I don't even remember who was talking.
- Jaz was alright.
She was kinda normal.
- She was kind of too independent.
I don't like it.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah,
- Kinda threw me off.
- I'm thinking if that
happened to me in public
and she came up to me with
a napkin and was like,
'cause you jack off too much in public.
I would be like, oh, maybe not.
- Because I didn't get the reference.
- I didn't get the reference.
So me and Jimmy were like, what the hell.
- In the last video I was like,
I rizzed in the bathroom beforehand.
And I rizzed in the
bathroom beforehand also.
And so then this time she took a tissue.
- It was a good callback.
- It was funny.
- No, I understand the callback,
but it also--
- No, that's cheating.
- In the context of it happening in a bar.
- Oh, that is true.
- You're not supposed to know that.
- True, true.
- It implies that I was
masturbating in public.
- Right.
Which I don't think--
- Which you weren't.
- No, I know I wouldn't.
I'm just saying if a girl came up to me
and was like, do you need some tissues,
I'd be like,
I'm kind of okay right here.
- Okay. We got it?
- Yeah.
- We good.
- Okay.
- Let's do it.
[Presenter] Cool.
- No, do it again.
- Okay.
(cast members laugh)
There is someone behind the camera
with a weapon.
- No.
- I woke up this morning with a blindfold.
- Oh my God.
- I don't know where I am.
I'm locked in this room.
- They said you have
to give us compliments,
- And they're saying,
- and watch our video.
- They're saying
you have to promote our videos right now.
I haven't eaten in four days.
- I was locked in a closet.
(upbeat music)
Aurora.
- I got last place.
- Yeah, well,
This is the explanation.
- It was, okay, so,
We love the confidence.
It was great,
but it was just kind of like--
- Overbearing.
- Yeah. It was a lot.
You know,
- Yeah.
- It was a little strong.
- Okay.
- I thought I'd be in
the middle, you know,
somewhere cute.
In the middle.
I was like, oh yeah,
I'm gonna be the top.
I didn't think I was gonna be the best
- Next.
Who's next?
- I think it was Jess.
- Napkin girl.
- Oh.
- The napkin girl.
- He almost said jizz napkin girl.
- 0% Shocked.
I thought I'd be last.
- No, but you gotta understand,
We didn't really, like,
get the reference.
- I liked the napkin thing.
I thought that was cool.
- Here's the thing,
I think you're great.
I've appreciated our
relationship together.
So I was thinking about it as if,
we're in a bar.
If a girl came up to me and was like,
"Do you need a napkin for
your jizz from the bathroom?"
I would be like--
- First of all, I said rizz.
- I was like, I'm not a predator.
- Okay.
(Jess laughs)
- All right.
- Who's the next one?
- It was Jaz.
- Jaz, Jaz.
(in unison)
- Jaz.
- You're next.
- Yeah.
- Fourth place.
- I mean, it was cool to, like,
say you're gonna take him out on a date,
you know?
Yeah, we did like that.
I liked that. That was pretty cool.
- Men need to be treated too.
- You wanted to take us out, you know.
- Recognizing the boys too.
- Of course.
- Right. It's, a night out, you know.
- Yeah, that's--
- Yeah,
- That's real.
- You did good.
(Jaz laughs)
- Third was Mai.
- Third was Mai, yeah.
- Mai, you did great.
You, did great Mai.
It's just--
that's why you did great.
- It was calm. It was cool.
It was a good combo.
- You played the bar scene good.
You were in the role, you know,
and you asked for the phone number.
- I'm not even like legal to go out guys.
So that was real improv. Okay.
- You never go out?
- I don't go to the bar.
- Oh,
- I can't get in.
- Second.
- And then you guys just swap places.
- Yeah.
- There we go.
- One, Two. Yes.
- You both did great.
- Erica. You did great.
You smelled wonderful.
(Erica laughs)
Made me feel real good inside.
Confident.
- No, we didn't like that.
- No, we, we liked it.
- Erica took good care of me.
I guess she smelled good. She looked good.
She did a little 360 around me.
That caught me off guard.
But I liked it.
- I love Garrett.
Garrett smells actually really nice.
- It was like 1A and one a 1B.
- Two firsts!
- To be honest.
Y'all were both, you know what I'm saying?
Y'all were both good.
- You did good.
- I'm just happy that I didn't get last
'cause my little brother grilled me.
He said if I got last,
he would disown me as a sister.
- She just killed it.
- Yeah, number one killed it.
- Yeah, she killed it.
- It was all natural.
Definitely confident.
Yeah.
- Errol started falling a little bit.
- Yeah, I know.
I was like.
She went first.
- I know.
- She went first and we're all like, oh.
- Yeah.
- Errol, would you have
grabbed her number if you--
- Oh no, of course.
Yeah. I'm grabbing her after.
- Y'all still like the best six
out of like a hundred women though.
You know what I mean?
- Aww.
- Y'all were all dope.
Y'all were all dope.
- We were forced to like--
- None of you guys were awkward and
none of you guys were weird.
- I expected a lot less.
Y'all came in with some
heat, I'm not gonna lie.
- 'Cause most girls
wouldn't even try to rizz.
- Right. Exactly.
- [Presenter] If a girl
wants to try to rizz Nut,
do you have any advice for them?
- Just be like normal.
I don't know.
Just come up and be like,
Hey,
And I'd be like, what's up?
- See, let's see.
- You have to guess what my
favorite number is first.
- Your favorite number?
- Yes.
- Seven.
- Nope. It's 951.
- That's why she's number one.
I like your nails by the way.
- Thank you.
- Of course.
- They're kind of overdue, but,
- Nah, I like them.
- I like them.
- All right.